als mittel dafür muss dann nur weil du
alter megaprojekt einfach mal 20 auf gar
nichts sparen benutzt kein windows nicht
nur zu gern merck preis welchen duft
sich von allen hier am besten finde es
anders im paradies angekommen rauchen
tötet dann hat gerade herausgefunden
dass sie auch zollfreie zigaretten
einkaufen davon spart dadurch noch 17
euro
bin ich hier gelandet
er war wir sind im hotel angekommen ich
bin erst noch die letzte gegangen durch
das machen die haben sogar in der
toilette dieses ding wo mitte den
arschloch einigen kannst da ist luxus
hier die wand zum restaurant besteht aus
einem aquarium
ich weiß nicht wo ich gelandet bin und
ich sind irgendwie in einem zimmer
gelandet die haben auch irgendwie ist es
auch unser tool und ich scheiß auf alles
wie gefällt euch ein trost dass er das
weniger durch den für den holzmarkt hier
sind kletterbäume
s
hingegen bin ich enorm fressen sind
immer noch gefragt wir sind hier beim
zweiten wurf
nee ich habe einfach so für meine
sammlung nur einfach geträumt ich hab
corona
ich habe jetzt natürlich getrunken das
war kein traum
wir sind jetzt heute auf dem pavillon an
dem steg und davon dass sogar fern von
mir auch lieber nehmen jetzt ganz gut
die kameraführung jetzt mal dran
ich fühle mich als wäre ich ein bisschen
zu nah ich darf nicht ob war ich glaube
ich bin zu dick uns geht es hier
ich lebe hier datei life leben gefühlt
da ich fühle mich wie immer dünner
august bestellt natürlich nein ich meine
auflud vorbestellt natürlich ich bin
noch aktuell auf diät denn du musst hier
[Gelächter]
hast du glück hast du das das sind
einfach gehen das einzige was du kennst
es von einem bratwürstchen war es der
leichten sonnenbrand
da ich wollte noch mal zeigen wo auch
immer ein gern fußball spielt ist das
der einzige der absolute traum was
machen wir jetzt fühl mich dass halo
sind sie meinen beifahrer in der lage
kann man ja gar nicht geschlagen
[Musik]
das ist übrigens so frühstücks der ort
wo man richtig fällt wird so sehe ich
nach dem frühstück dann aus sie
besichtigen heute und will hier beim
hotel
das ist die einfache regel ich wollte
mich damit entziehen gehört mit stopp
fiel aus das ist meine badewanne hier
drunter durch sich halt immer natürlich
dann noch ein bisschen aber hier war ich
halt und da kann ich mir dann halt ein
bisschen angestrengt hat sich das auch
wenn man da rauszubringen hier und hier
ist dann nochmal sonst immer mit
whirlpool mit kamin mit normalen mini
garten von mirka kann halt immer mal
vier stunden meiner badewanne da vorne
geht es dann hier über an der bar lang
sandstrand erfordert mein anderer pool
es geht ganz dem fenster hier sind
übrigens schuss sicher weil ist halt so
wenn ich was denkt sie teils die bude
mein ganzes geld wenn man von
vorneherein geht sieht man erst mal das
ja und das hier
und leider auch dass hier wir sind jetzt
hier in spa bereich und diese vier
geräte zusammen kosten wie viel geben
100.000 euro ist so eine geisteskranke
villa sogar eigener aufzug ich glaube in
ratten rum das ist einfach der
playstation
da bin ich heute meine beine nicht auch
nicht lassen
zum golfplatz kann man das handy
wenn ich hier wohne alt hat er braucht
keinen sport mehr machen das jetzt so
das konferenzzimmer hier sitzen nur so
erdogan obama und so die bahn schnalle
hier und hier so gespräche dass er
natürlich auch
[Musik]
baby und ich mache jetzt so eine
behandlung wo einem berg ganz direkt vom
körper gestoppt werden daher unsichtbar
sein
das war seine partner wie lange
nebeneinander dann wieder gewaschen
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt ja gerade ins land of
legends gefahren nicht keine ahnung
warum zu heiß aber es ist auf jeden fall
wunderschön hier die sache ist ich bin
eigentlich hier mit revier und wir
suchen unsere freunde aber recht einfach
100 meter vor mir und bin einfach nicht
warten
aber ich habe keinen bock schnell zu
laufen jetzt einfach 50.000 grad das
wasser ist auch ein fachmann ran jetzt
danach danach werde ich sie ganz bewusst
ich dass du hier bist dann habe ich aber
alle verloren und jetzt habe ich mir
einfach geld auf dieses komische dinge
und jetzt normalen hunger aber das ist
geschlossen und hier da war ich jetzt
kürzer holz war auch geschlossen
ich fühle mich da dieses eine kind auf
diesem geburtstag was nicht spart sogar
heute als jetzt waren die darunter und
jetzt fahren die da wieder auch ich weiß
nicht
dann sind noch auf anderen achterbahn
aber sander und ich habe so krass hunger
das wird schon mal zum hotel fahren die
anderen immer noch eine weg von essen
dann noch nicht einfach allein für abend
wir haben wieder gefunden
zuerst was er macht schokolade kaufen
morgen wir uns diese hängen
maria bello fünf sternen
heute sind wir jetzt irgendwie in so
einem wasserpark ich glaube es einige
die rutsche verstopfen sie herzlich zu
essen und kleinen salat bestellt man
gibt anton er hat sich so 10.000 lammert
schon bestellt jetzt die ganzen tag mehr
warum sind wir nicht im zimmer revue
update nach einer stunde sind jetzt mit
kettensägen angekommen allerdings geht
die tür noch immer nicht auf jetzt
sitzen wir hier
ungeduscht und stinkend aber das tun wir
immer wenn wir ein zimmer angekommen
ja gut geschlafen ein neuer tag im
paradies das einzige was nicht so
paradiesisch
ein neuer tag im paradies ist das
einzige was nicht so paradiesisch ist
unser obama frühstückt ja jetzt kommt
einfach vom türkischer star friseur ins
hotel und schneidet uns die haare sagen
ganz fertig
brandt vom langston sonnenbrand
ja
vielleicht
wie lässt sich hier so unnormal
professionelle aufnahmen für seinen blog
macht anlagen gibt es nicht
es heißt dass ich mich die ganze zeit
fordern vor zehn jahren jemand dem
kleinen luca gesagt hätte dass ich
irgendwann in seinem stadion stehen bald
vor mir her kicker aus der anderen ecke
steht lukas podolski hätte ich
wahrscheinlich gegen charakters gekotzt
herr magath im stadion noch ein paar
tricks haben bilder ich kriege natürlich
betrunken aber ich mir jetzt meine
familie haben hatten sich auf den platz
eilte ich kann mir also komplett normal
gibt's andacht und bestellt sich einfach
direkt vom 11
diese lied geboren und hat das auch vom
motorrad rum und wir bleiben immer noch
einen kaffee den trainer nicht so machen
aufgrund der ganzen wilden tiere hier um
das hotel herum haben die halt überall
so richtig hohe zäune aufgestellt dass
sie hat nicht reinkommen praktisch
sondern dass auch hier
ich bin noch aktuell auf diät
der bescheid
dem rasen sehen so wasser gestellt
das team gewann in basel vor heben sich
sie jetzt vorbei
neuerdings bin ich dein onkel mal die
eigentlich der typ dahin wird ein
sonnenbrand bekommen von venedig super
toll fand aber auch disneyland supertoll
joker schwank einmal ganz kurz rüber und
fand es schön ich kann doch auch mal
schön empfand aber auch die wandfarben
und das ist 1 wir wagen hat unseren
verfügen laden ich habe mir auch ein
paar film geholt allerdings hat die
verkäuferin hat ende die ganze folge
gefasst werden sollte und was im moment
und wir sind jetzt hier bei irgendeiner
angekommen
[Musik]
ich habe mich für die nächsten ausgebuht
gemacht
ebenso eine show aber mein ich habe mich
zum flughafen gefahren weil wir zum
corona test machen da
falls euch interessiert aber noch nicht
in corona gedruckt deswegen wollten wir
testen
[Musik]
der mann beim gehirn obwohl ich ganz ab
unser test allerdings negativ durch wir
sind geladen
was wir sind natürlich mal wieder
überhaupt nichts gefilmt flug aber es
war auch ein stinknormaler flug halt
dieser geflogen verkraftbar wenn in der
luft feuer captain ist zwar sagen kommt
meiner lieben freund ich weiß nicht sagt
manchen captain bin aber ich bin auf
jeden fall froh dass müde werde
dementsprechend jetzt direkt
schlafengehen ich glaube man sieht es
mir gar nicht anders ich müde bin gar
nicht auf jeden fall jedoch noch mal ein
ganz ganz kleines dankeschön und ein
riesiger kurz raus wenn du was bedeutet
er wird eingeladen hat in die türkei ist
auf jeden fall mega mega cool ich war
noch nie in der türkei und diese woche
urlaub hat mir auch echt richtig gut
getan unser negatives corona
testergebnis mussten wir jetzt hier am
flughafen allerdings irgendwie niemandem
zeigen
allerdings würde ich den blog an der
stelle jetzt auch beenden bei der lieben
freunde wenn euch dieser sieben tage
zusammenfassung was auch immer gefallen
hat dann küsst meinen rechten 10
[Musik]